this is a film about someone who shoots
pictures was that a very different sort
of film to shoot for you yes it's one of
the films you have to do when you get
the script like this you just have to do
it it's it's it's easy to relate to even
though I'm never being a war
photographer it's I think I think most
of us working in the industry have been
away from home and so to to be one step
removed as someone else was taking the
pictures to take the pictures of that
how difficult was that now that was the
so we we got a lot of help from from to
various of three very good photographers
war photographers sorry especially that
helped yet to become the war
photographer they joined us from a lot
of the of the shoots where we had most
difficult shoots so and and Juliette was
very focused on being professional war
photographer doing everything in white
and she needs she got some memory cards
that was Paul and she said no I think I
need a bigger memory card because and
then she had to get the real ones yes
because if it didn't fit right so she
did she was very precise how did you
create a visual change of mood and
contrast with Ireland Afghanistan Kenya
I mean you get a little bit for free
because Ireland Ireland it's very
different and of course as also we
because we started up to the film by me
and Eric we went to Afghanistan to Kabul
with a very small camera so we we will
they're awesome I got the flavour of the
real place we shot only plates for when
she looks out of the car when she
entered the city that is Kabul the the
director Eric said that when you shot in
Afghanistan you were shooting maybe 25
minutes at
I'm and then you would go away for a
while was it a very sensitive
circumstance for you yes because when we
lend as I mean the story is about female
suicide bombers and one of the when
before we started to make the film we
got a lot of people saying that that
doesn't doesn't exist there is no female
suicide bombers when we landed four
hours after we landed we I was raped by
this emergency phone saying that we
shouldn't leave the place where we
stayed because that being a suicide
attack to female in the car exploding a
bus with some American people I think 20
people got killed so that was the
beginning but you felt that you had to
be very low-key yeah I mean when you
they can expand it's easy to to be
misunderstood that you are carrying and
gone or something with a long lens so
careful but in Hollywood so much of
filmmaking is about making the actors
look good that doesn't seem like it was
necessarily the priority for you it was
a very special thing because we have men
for me to to work with Juliet it was the
first thing I did was to go in I met her
in her hotel room
I remember just without I took it with a
very small camera and played around with
her face and and and we start to talk
about just what you said because this is
not a film era can always protect as you
would normally do where they start the
face and with the lighting and
everything but that was a concept and
she really wanted to be like that of
course we did I mean I actually created
a light for her know called softbox
Juliette for the close-ups so we had
some are you going to call that it
for every other film - or change the
name recording the circumstance now it
it's it's the name actually it was I was
asked by another story is that the right
name yes it is
sorry it's the story but it was yes made
for lightweight light that we can carry
around for him but still yes as you said
it's not that was not the main goal was
there not a temptation to make it look
prettier of course I'm a trained
photographer cinematographer you you
have that back in your mind always but
it it was so important I mean the film
is as you probably see we with the whole
film is shot with actually yet we never
go into a room like without her we
always see the room exactly when she
sees the room we never leave it lighter
than her we see everything through her
person so it's it's it's a film where
you it's made in a documentary way
trying to create something that should
feel real given that you were seeing
everything through her character's eyes
did she collaborate with you in that
vision oh yes and also we we agreed on
cause one thing when you were
professionals similar however I shot I
think 28 30 features you have this you
get so professional that you you you
behave the camera in a way that you it's
always perfect in a way you can you know
how to do it there are certain scenes in
the film why I didn't want to know I
didn't want to know which door she
entered the scene just to to confuse
myself on the first take
to get something that was unique
something that got this kind of
documentary feeling so it was a
different approach than I normally do